The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so welcome to
6.041/6.431, the class on
probability models
and the like.
I'm John Tsitsiklis.
I will be teaching this class,
and I'm looking forward to
this being an enjoyable and
also useful experience.
We have a fair amount of staff
involved in this course, your
recitation instructors and also
a bunch of TAs, but I
want to single out our head
TA, Uzoma, who is the key
person in this class.
Everything has to
go through him.
If he doesn't know in which
recitation section you are,
then simply you do not exist,
so keep that in mind.
All right.
So we want to jump right into
the subject, but I'm going to
take just a few minutes
to talk about a few
administrative details and
how the course is run.
So we're going to have lectures
twice a week and I'm
going to use old fashioned
transparencies.
Now, you get copies of these
slides with plenty of space
for you to keep notes on them.
A useful way of making good use
of the slides is to use
them as a sort of mnemonic
summary of
what happens in lecture.
Not everything that I'm going
to say is, of course, on the
slides, but by looking them you
get the sense of what's
happening right now.
And it may be a good idea to
review them before you go to
recitation.
So what happens in recitation?
In recitation, your recitation
instructor is going to maybe
review some of the theory
and then solve some
problems for you.
And then you have tutorials
where you meet in very small
groups together with your TA.
And what happens in tutorials
is that you actually do the
problem solving with the help
of your TA and the help of
your classmates in your
tutorial section.
Now probability is
a tricky subject.
You may be reading the text,
listening to lectures,
everything makes perfect sense,
and so on, but until
you actually sit down and try
to solve problems, you don't
quite appreciate the
subtleties and the
difficulties that
are involved.
So problem solving is a key
part of this class.
And tutorials are extremely
useful just for this reason
because that's where you
actually get the practice of
solving problems on your own,
as opposed to seeing someone
else who's solving
them for you.
OK but, mechanics, a key part
of what's going to happen
today is that you will turn in
your schedule forms that are
at the end of the handout that
you have in your hands.
Then, the TAs will be working
frantically through the night,
and they're going to be
producing a list of who goes
into what section.
And when that happens, any
person in this class, with
probability 90%, is going to be
happy with their assignment
and, with probability 10%,
they're going to be unhappy.
Now, unhappy people have
an option, though.
You can resubmit your form
together with your full
schedule and constraints, give
it back to the head TA, who
will then do some further
juggling and reassign people,
and after that happens, 90% of
those unhappy people will
become happy.
And 10% of them will
be less unhappy.
OK.
So what's the probability that a
random person is going to be
unhappy at the end
of this process?
It's 1%.
Excellent.
Good.
Maybe you don't need
this class.
OK, so 1%.
We have about 100 people in this
class, so there's going
to be about one unhappy
person.
I mean, anywhere you look in
life, in any group you look
at, there's always one unhappy
person, right?
So, what can we do about it?
All right.
Another important part about
mechanics is to read carefully
the statement that we have about
collaboration, academic
honesty, and all that.
You're encouraged, it's
a very good idea to
work with other students.
You can consult sources that
are out there, but when you
sit down and write your
solutions you have to do that
by setting things aside and just
write them on your own.
You cannot copy something
that somebody else
has given to you.
One reason is that we're not
going to like it when it
happens, and then another reason
is that you're not
going to do yourself
any favor.
Really the only way to do well
in this class is to get a lot
of practice by solving
problems yourselves.
So if you don't do that on your
own, then when quiz and
exam time comes, things are
going to be difficult.
So, as I mentioned here, we're
going to have recitation
sections, that some of them are
for 6.041 students, some
are for 6.431 students, the
graduate section of the class.
Now undergraduates
can sit in the
graduate recitation sections.
What's going to happen there is
that things may be just a
little faster and you may be
covering a problem that's a
little more advanced and
is not covered in
the undergrad sections.
But if you sit in the graduate
section, and you're an
undergraduate, you're still
just responsible for the
undergraduate material.
That is, you can just do the
undergraduate work in the
class, but maybe be exposed
at the different section.
OK.
A few words about the
style of this class.
We want to focus on basic
ideas and concepts.
There's going to be lots of
formulas, but what we try to
do in this class is to actually
have you understand
what those formulas mean.
And, in a year from now when
almost all of the formulas
have been wiped out from your
memory, you still have the
basic concepts.
You can understand them, so when
you look things up again,
they will still make sense.
It's not the plug and chug kind
of class where you're
given a list of formulas, you're
given numbers, and you
plug in and you get answers.
The really hard part is usually
to choose which
formulas you're going to use.
You need judgment, you
need intuition.
Lots of probability problems, at
least the interesting ones,
often have lots of different
solutions.
Some are extremely long, some
are extremely short.
The extremely short ones usually
involve some kind of
deeper understanding of what's
going on so that you can pick
a shortcut and use it.
And hopefully you are going
to develop this
skill during this class.
Now, I could spend a lot of time
in this lecture talking
about why the subject
is important.
I'll keep it short because I
think it's almost obvious.
Anything that happens in
life is uncertain.
There's uncertainty anywhere, so
whatever you try to do, you
need to have some way of dealing
or thinking about this
uncertainty.
And the way to do that in a
systematic way is by using the
models that are given to us
by probability theory.
So if you're an engineer and
you're dealing with a
communication system or signal
processing, basically you're
facing a fight against noise.
Noise is random, is uncertain.
How do you model it?
How do you deal with it?
If you're a manager, I guess
you're dealing with customer
demand, which is, of
course, random.
Or you're dealing with the
stock market, which is
definitely random.
Or you play the casino, which
is, again, random, and so on.
And the same goes for pretty
much any other field that you
can think of.
But, independent of which field
you're coming from, the
basic concepts and tools are
really all the same.
So you may see in bookstores
that there are books,
probability for scientists,
probability for engineers,
probability for social
scientists, probability for
astrologists.
Well, what all those books have
inside them is exactly
the same models, the same
equations, the same problems.
They just make them somewhat
different word problems.
The basic concepts are just one
and the same, and we'll
take this as an excuse for not
going too much into specific
domain applications.
We will have problems and
examples that are motivated,
in some loose sense, from
real world situations.
But we're not really trying in
this class to develop the
skills for domain-specific
problems.
Rather, we're going to try to
stick to general understanding
of the subject.
OK.
So the next slide, of which you
do have in your handout,
gives you a few more details
about the class.
Maybe one thing to comment here
is that you do need to
read the text.
And with calculus books, perhaps
you can live with a
just a two page summary of all
of the interesting formulas in
calculus, and you can get by
just with those formulas.
But here, because we want
to develop concepts and
intuition, actually reading
words, as opposed to just
browsing through equations,
does make a difference.
In the beginning, the class
is kind of easy.
When we deal with discrete
probability, that's the
material until our first quiz,
and some of you may get by
without being too systematic
about following the material.
But it does get substantially
harder afterwards.
And I would keep restating that
you do have to read the
text to really understand
the material.
OK.
So now we can start with the
real part of the lecture.
Let us set the goals
for today.
So probability, or probability
theory, is a framework for
dealing with uncertainty, for
dealing with situations in
which we have some kind
of randomness.
So what we want to do is, by the
end of today's lecture, to
give you anything that you need
to know how to set up
what does it take to set up
a probabilistic model.
And what are the basic rules of
the game for dealing with
probabilistic models?
So, by the end of this lecture,
you will have
essentially recovered
half of this
semester's tuition, right?
So we're going to talk
about probabilistic
models in more detail--
the sample space, which is
basically a description of all
the things that may happen
during a random experiment,
and the probability law, which
describes our beliefs about
which outcomes are more
likely to occur
compared to other outcomes.
Probability laws have to obey
certain properties that we
call the axioms of
probability.
So the main part of today's
lecture is to describe those
axioms, which are the rules of
the game, and consider a few
really trivial examples.
OK, so let's start
with our agenda.
The first piece in a
probabilistic model is a
description of the sample
space of an experiment.
So we do an experiment, and by
experiment we just mean that
just something happens
out there.
And that something that happens,
it could be flipping
a coin, or it could be rolling
a dice, or it could be doing
something in a card game.
So we fix a particular
experiment.
And we come up with a list of
all the possible things that
may happen during
this experiment.
So we write down a list of all
the possible outcomes.
So here's a list of all the
possible outcomes of the
experiment.
I use the word "list," but, if
you want to be a little more
formal, it's better to think
of that list as a set.
So we have a set.
That set is our sample space.
And it's a set whose elements
are the possible outcomes of
the experiment.
So, for example, if you're
dealing with flipping a coin,
your sample space would be
heads, this is one outcome,
tails is one outcome.
And this set, which has two
elements, is the sample space
of the experiment.
OK.
What do we need to think about
when we're setting up the
sample space?
First, the list should be
mutually exclusive,
collectively exhaustive.
What does that mean?
Collectively exhaustive means
that, no matter what happens
in the experiment, you're
going to get one of the
outcomes inside here.
So you have not forgotten any
of the possibilities of what
may happen in the experiment.
Mutually exclusive means that
if this happens, then that
cannot happen.
So at the end of the experiment,
you should be able
to point out to me just one,
exactly one, of these outcomes
and say, this is the outcome
that happened.
OK.
So these are sort of
basic requirements.
There's another requirement
which is a little more loose.
When you set up your sample
space, sometimes you do have
some freedom about the details
of how you're going to
describe it.
And the question is,
how much detail are
you going to include?
So let's take this coin flipping
experiment and think
of the following sample space.
One possible outcome is heads,
a second possible outcome is
tails and it's raining, and the
third possible outcome is
tails and it's not raining.
So this is another possible
sample space for the
experiment where I flip
a coin just once.
It's a legitimate one.
These three possibilities are
mutually exclusive and
collectively exhaustive.
Which one is the right
sample space?
Is it this one or that one?
Well, if you think that my coin
flipping inside this room
is completely unrelated to the
weather outside, then you're
going to stick with
this sample space.
If, on the other hand, you have
some superstitious belief
that maybe rain has an effect
on my coins, you might work
with the sample space
of this kind.
So you probably wouldn't do
that, but it's a legitimate
option, strictly speaking.
Now this example is a little bit
on the frivolous side, but
the issue that comes up here is
a basic one that shows up
anywhere in science
and engineering.
Whenever you're dealing with a
model or with a situation,
there are zillions of details
in that situation.
And when you come up with a
model, you choose some of
those details that you keep in
your model, and some that you
say, well, these
are irrelevant.
Or maybe there are small
effects, I can neglect them,
and you keep them outside
your model.
So when you go to the real
world, there's definitely an
element of art and some judgment
that you need to do
in order to set up an
appropriate sample space.
So, an easy example now.
So of course, the elementary
examples are
coins, cards, and dice.
So let's deal with dice.
But to keep the diagram small,
instead of a six-sided die,
we're going to think about the
die that only has four faces.
So you can do that with
a tetrahedron,
doesn't really matter.
Basically, it's a die that when
you roll it, you get a
result which is one,
two, three or four.
However, the experiment that I'm
going to think about will
consist of two rolls
of a dice.
A crucial point here--
I'm rolling the die twice, but
I'm thinking of this as just
one experiment, not two
different experiments, not a
repetition twice of the
same experiment.
So it's one big experiment.
During that big experiment
various things could happen,
such as I'm rolling the
die once, and then I'm
rolling the die twice.
OK.
So what's the sample space
for that experiment?
Well, the sample space
consists of
the possible outcomes.
One possible outcome is that
your first roll resulted in
two and the second roll
resulted in three.
In which case, the outcome that
you get is this one, a
two followed by three.
This is one possible outcome.
The way I'm describing things,
this outcome is to be
distinguished from this outcome
here, where a three is
followed by two.
If you're playing backgammon, it
doesn't matter which one of
the two happened.
But if you're dealing with a
probabilistic model that you
want to keep track of everything
that happens in
this composite experiment, there
are good reasons for
distinguishing between
these two outcomes.
I mean, when this happens,
it's definitely something
different from that happening.
A two followed by a three is
different from a three
followed by a two.
So this is the correct sample
space for this experiment
where we roll the die twice.
It has a total of 16 elements
and it's, of
course, a finite set.
Sometimes, instead of describing
sample spaces in
terms of lists, or sets, or
diagrams of this kind, it's
useful to describe
the experiment in
some sequential way.
Whenever you have an experiment
that consists of
multiple stages, it might be
useful, at least visually, to
give a diagram that shows you
how those stages evolve.
And that's what we do by using
a sequential description or a
tree-based description by
drawing a tree of the possible
evolutions during
our experiment.
So in this tree, I'm thinking
of a first stage in which I
roll the first die, and there
are four possible results,
one, two, three and
four.and 4.
And, given what happened, let's
say in the first roll,
suppose I got a one.
Then I'm rolling the second
dice, and there are four
possibilities for what may
happen to the second die.
And the possible results
are one, tow,
three and four again.
So what's the relation between
the two diagrams?
Well, for example, the outcome
two followed by three
corresponds to this
path on the tree.
So this path corresponds to
two followed by a three.
Any path is associated to a
particular outcome, any
outcome is associated to
a particular path.
And, instead of paths, you may
want to think in terms of the
leaves of this diagram.
Same thing, think of each one
of the leaves as being one
possible outcome.
And of course we have 16
outcomes here, we have 16
outcomes here.
Maybe you noticed the subtlety
that I used in my language.
I said I rolled the first
dice and the result
that I get is a two.
I didn't use the word "outcome."
I want to reserve
the word "outcome" to mean the
overall outcome at the end of
the overall experiment.
So "2, 3" is the outcome
of the experiment.
The experiment consisted
of stages.
Two was the result in the first
stage, three was the
result in the second stage.
You put all those results
together, and
you get your outcome.
OK, perhaps we are splitting
hairs here, but it's useful to
keep the concepts right.
What's special about this
example is that, besides being
trivial, it has a sample
space which is finite.
There's 16 possible
total outcomes.
Not every experiment has
a finite sample space.
Here's an experiment in which
the sample space is infinite.
So you are playing darts and
the target is this square.
And you're perfect at that game,
so you're sure that your
darts will always fall
inside the square.
So, but where exactly your dart
would fall inside that
square, that itself is random.
We don't know what
it's going to be.
It's uncertain.
So all the possible points
inside the square are possible
outcomes of the experiment.
So a typical outcome of the
experiment is going to a pair
of numbers, x,y, where x
and y are real numbers
between zero and one.
Now there's infinitely many
real numbers, there's
infinitely many points in the
square, so this is an example
in which our sample space
is an infinite set.
OK, so we're going to revisit
this example a little later.
So these are two examples of
what the sample space might be
in simple experiments.
Now, the more important order of
business is now to look at
those possible outcomes and to
make some statements about
their relative likelihoods.
Which outcome is more
likely to occur
compared to the others?
And the way we do this
is by assigning
probabilities to the outcomes.
Well, not exactly.
Suppose that all you were to do
was to assign probabilities
to individual outcomes.
If you go back to this example,
and you consider one
particular outcome-- let's
say this point--
what would be the probability
that you hit exactly this
point to infinite precision?
Intuitively, that probability
would be zero.
So any individual point in this
diagram in any reasonable
model should have zero
probability.
So if you just tell me that
any individual outcome has
zero probability, you're
not really telling me
much to work with.
For that reason, what instead
we're going to do is to assign
probabilities to subsets of the
sample space, as opposed
to assigning probabilities
to individual outcomes.
So here's the picture.
We have our sample space,
which is omega, and we
consider some subset of
the sample space.
Call it A. And I want to assign
a number, a numerical
probability, to this particular
subset which
represents my belief about how
likely this set is to occur.
OK.
What do we mean "to occur?"
And I'm introducing here a
language that's being used
in probability theory.
When we talk about subsets of
the sample space, we usually
call them events, as
opposed to subsets.
And the reason is because it
works nicely with the language
that describes what's
going on.
So the outcome is a point.
The outcome is random.
The outcome may be inside this
set, in which case we say that
event A occurred, if we get
an outcome inside here.
Or the outcome may fall outside
the set, in which case
we say that event
A did not occur.
So we're going to assign
probabilities to events.
And now, how should we
do this assignment?
Well, probabilities are meant to
describe your beliefs about
which sets are more likely to
occur versus other sets.
So there's many ways that
you can assign those
probabilities.
But there are some ground
rules for this game.
First, we want probabilities to
be numbers between zero and
one because that's the
usual convention.
So a probability of zero means
we're certain that something
is not going to happen.
Probability of one means that
we're essentially certain that
something's going to happen.
So we want numbers between
zero and one.
We also want a few
other things.
And those few other things are
going to be encapsulated in a
set of axioms.
What "axioms" means in this
context, it's the ground rules
that any legitimate
probabilistic
model should obey.
You have a choice of what kind
of probabilities you use.
But, no matter what you use,
they should obey certain
consistency properties because
if they obey those properties,
then you can go ahead and do
useful calculations and do
some useful reasoning.
So what are these properties?
First, probabilities should
be non-negative.
OK?
That's our convention.
We want probabilities to be
numbers between zero and one.
So they should certainly
be non-negative.
The probability that event
A occurs should be a
non-negative number.
What's the second axiom?
The probability of the entire
sample space is equal to one.
Why does this make sense?
Well, the outcome is certain to
be an element of the sample
space because we set up a
sample space, which is
collectively exhaustive.
No matter what the outcome is,
it's going to be an element of
the sample space.
We're certain that event omega
is going to occur.
Therefore, we represent this
certainty by saying that the
probability of omega
is equal to one.
Pretty straightforward so far.
The more interesting axiom
is the third rule.
Before getting into it,
just a quick reminder.
If you have two sets, A and B,
the intersection of A and B
consists of those elements that
belong both to A and B.
And we denote it this way.
When you think
probabilistically, the way to
think of intersection is by
using the word "and." This
event, this intersection, is the
event that A occurred and
B occurred.
If I get an outcome inside here,
A has occurred and B has
occurred at the same time.
So you may find the word "and"
to be a little more convenient
than the word "intersection."
And similarly, we have some
notation for the union of two
events, which we
write this way.
The union of two sets, or two
events, is the collection of
all the elements that belong
either to the first set, or to
the second, or to both.
When you talk about events, you
can use the word "or." So
this is the event that A
occurred or B occurred.
And this "or" means that it
could also be that both of
them occurred.
OK.
So now that we have this
notation, what does
the third axiom say?
The third axiom says that if we
have two events, A and B,
that have no common elements--
so here's A, here's B,
and perhaps this is
our big sample space.
The two events have no
common elements.
So the intersection of the two
events is the empty set.
There's nothing in their
intersection.
Then, the total probability of
A together with B has to be
equal to the sum of the
individual probabilities.
So the probability that A occurs
or B occurs is equal to
the probability that
A occurs plus the
probability that B occurs.
So think of probability
as being cream cheese.
You have one pound of cream
cheese, the total probability
assigned to the entire
sample space.
And that cream cheese is spread
out over this set.
The probability of A is how much
cream cheese sits on top
of A. Probability of B is how
much sits on top of B. The
probability of A union B is
the total amount of cream
cheese sitting on top of this
and that, which is obviously
the sum of how much is
sitting here and how
much is sitting there.
So probabilities behave
like cream cheese, or
they behave like mass.
For example, if you think of
some material object, the mass
of this set consisting of two
pieces is obviously the sum of
the two masses.
So this property is a
very intuitive one.
It's a pretty natural
one to have.
OK.
Are these axioms enough for
what we want to do?
I mentioned a while ago that
we want probabilities to be
numbers between zero and one.
Here's an axiom that tells you
that probabilities are
non-negative.
Should we have another axiom
that tells us that
probabilities are less
than or equal to one?
It's a desirable property.
We would like to have
it in our hands.
OK, why is it not
in that list?
Well, the people who are in the
axiom making business are
mathematicians and
mathematicians tend to be
pretty laconic.
You don't say something if
you don't have to say it.
And this is the case here.
We don't need that extra axiom
because we can derive it from
the existing axioms.
Here's how it goes.
One is the probability over
the entire sample space.
Here we're using the
second axiom.
Now the sample space consists
of A together with the
complement of A. OK?
When I write the complement of
A, I mean the complement of A
inside of the set omega.
So we have omega, here's A,
here's the complement of A,
and the overall set is omega.
OK.
Now, what's the next step?
What should I do next?
Which axiom should I use?
We use axiom three because a set
and the complement of that
set are disjoint.
They don't have any
common elements.
So axiom three applies and
tells me that this is the
probability of A plus the
probability of A complement.
In particular, the probability
of A is equal to one minus the
probability of A complement,
and this is less
than or equal to one.
Why?
Because probabilities
are non-negative,
by the first axiom.
OK.
So we got the conclusion
that we wanted.
Probabilities are always less
than or equal to one, and this
is a simple consequence of the
three axioms that we have.
This is a really nice argument
because it actually uses each
one of those axioms.
The argument is simple, but you
have to use all of these
three properties to get the
conclusion that you want.
OK.
So we can get interesting things
out of our axioms.
Can we get some more
interesting ones?
How about the union
of three sets?
What kind of probability
should it have?
So here's an event consisting
of three pieces.
And I want to say something
about the probability of A
union B union C. What I would
like to say is that this
probability is equal to the sum
of the three individual
probabilities.
How can I do it?
I have an axiom that
tells me that I can
do it for two events.
I don't have an axiom
for three events.
Well, maybe I can manage things
and still be able to
use that axiom.
And here's the trick.
The union of three sets, you can
think of it as forming the
union of the first two sets and
then taking the union with
the third set.
OK?
So taking unions, you can
take the unions in any
order that you want.
So here we have the
union of two sets.
Now, ABC are disjoint,
by assumption or
that's how I drew it.
So if A, B, and C are disjoint,
then A union B is
disjoint from C. So here
we have the union of
two disjoint sets.
So by the additivity axiom, the
probability of that the
union is going to be the
probability of the first set
plus the probability
of the second set.
And now I can use the additivity
axiom once more to
write that this is probability
of A plus probability of B
plus probability of C. So by
using this axiom which was
stated for two sets, we can
actually derive a similar
property for the union of
three disjoint sets.
And then you can repeat
this argument as many
times as you want.
It's valid for the union of
ten disjoint sets, for the
union of a hundred disjoint
sets, for the union of any
finite number of sets.
So if A1 up to An are disjoint,
then the probability
of A1 union An is equal to the
sum of the probabilities of
the individual sets.
OK.
Special case of this
is when we're
dealing with finite sets.
Suppose I have just a finite
set of outcomes.
I put them together in a set
and I'm interested in the
probability of that set.
So here's our sample space.
There's lots of outcomes, but
I'm taking a few of these and
I form a set out of them.
This is a set consisting
of, in this
picture, three elements.
In general, it consists
of k elements.
Now, a finite set, I can write
it as a union of single
element sets.
So this set here is the union
of this one element set,
together with this one element
set together with that one
element set.
So the total probability of this
set is going to be the
sum of the probabilities of
the one element sets.
Now, probability of a one
element set, you need to use
the brackets here because
probabilities
are assigned to sets.
But this gets kind of tedious,
so here one abuses notation a
little bit and we get rid of
those brackets and just write
probability of this single,
individual outcome.
In any case, conclusion from
this exercise is that the
total probability of a finite
collection of possible
outcomes, the total probability
is equal to the
sum of the probabilities
of individual elements.
So these are basically the
axioms of probability theory.
Or, well, they're almost
the axioms.
There are some subtleties
that are involved here.
One subtlety is that this axiom
here doesn't quite do
the job for everything
we would like to do.
And we're going to come
back to this at
the end of the lecture.
A second subtlety has to
do with weird sets.
We said that an event is a
subset of the sample space and
we assign probabilities
to events.
Does this mean that we are going
to assign probability to
every possible subset
of the sample space?
Ideally, we would
wish to do that.
Unfortunately, this is
not always possible.
If you take a sample space, such
as the square, the square
has nice subsets, those that you
can describe by cutting it
with lines and so on.
But it does have some very ugly
subsets, as well, that
are impossible to visualize,
impossible to imagine, but
they do exist.
And those very weird sets are
such that there's no way to
assign probabilities to them
in a way that's consistent
with the axioms of
probability.
OK.
So this is a very, very fine
point that you can immediately
forget for the rest
of this class.
You will only encounter these
sets if you end up doing
doctoral work on the theoretical
aspects of
probability theory.
So it's just a mathematical
subtlety that some very weird
sets do not have probabilities
assigned to them.
But we're not going to encounter
these sets and they
do not show up in any
applications.
OK.
So now let's revisit
our examples.
Let's go back to the
die example.
We have our sample space.
Now we need to assign
a probability law.
There's lots of possible
probability laws
that you can assign.
I'm picking one here,
arbitrarily, in which I say
that every possible outcome
has the same
probability of 1/16.
OK.
Why do I make this model?
Well, empirically, if you have
well-manufactured dice, they
tend to behave that way.
We will be coming back
to this kind of story
later in this class.
But I'm not saying that this
is the only probability law
that there can be.
You might have weird dice in
which certain outcomes are
more likely than others.
But to keep things simple, let's
take every outcome to
have the same probability
of 1/16.
OK.
Now that we have in our hands
a sample space and the
probability law, we can
actually solve any
problem there is.
We can answer any question that
could be posed to us.
For example, what's the
probability that the outcome,
which is this pair, is
either 1,1 or 1,2.
We're talking here about this
particular event, 1,1 or 1,2.
So it's an event consisting
of these two items.
According to what we were just
discussing, the probability of
a finite collection of outcomes
is the sum of their
individual probabilities.
Each one of them has probability
of 1/16, so the
probability of this is 2/16.
How about the probability of the
event that x is equal to
one. x is the first roll, so
that's the probability that
the first roll is
equal to one.
Notice the syntax that's
being used here.
Probabilities are assigned to
subsets, to sets, so we think
of this as meaning the set of
all outcomes such that x is
equal to one.
How do you answer
this question?
You go back to the picture and
you try to visualize or
identify this event
of interest.
x is equal to one corresponds
to this event here.
These are all the outcomes at
which x is equal to one.
There's four outcomes.
Each one has probability 1/16,
so the answer is 4/16.
OK.
How about the probability
that x plus y is odd?
OK.
That will take a little
bit more work.
But you go to the sample space
and you identify all the
outcomes at which the sum
is an odd number.
So that's a place where the sum
is odd, these are other
places, and I guess that
exhausts all the possible
outcomes at which we
have an odd sum.
We count them.
How many are there?
There's a total of
eight of them.
Each one has probability 1/16,
total probability is 8/16.
And harder question.
What is the probability that the
minimum of the two rolls
is equal to 2?
This is something that you
probably couldn't do in your
head without the help
of a diagram.
But once you have a diagram,
things are simple.
You ask the question.
OK, this is an event, that the
minimum of the two rolls is
equal to two.
This can happen in
several ways.
What are the several ways
that it can happen?
Go to the diagram and try
to identify them.
So the minimum is equal to two
if both of them are two's.
Or it could be that x is two and
y is bigger, or y is two
and x is bigger.
OK.
I guess we rediscover that
yellow and blue make green, so
we see here that there's
a total of
five possible outcomes.
The probability of this
event is 5/16.
Simple example, but the
procedure that we followed in
this example actually applies
to any probability model you
might ever encounter.
You set up your sample space,
you make a statement that
describes the probability law
over that sample space, then
somebody asks you questions
about various events.
You go to your pictures,
identify those events, pin
them down, and then start kind
of counting and calculating
the total probability for those
outcomes that you're
considering.
This example is a special case
of what is called the discrete
uniform law.
The model obeys the discrete
uniform law if all outcomes
are equally likely.
It doesn't have to
be that way.
That's just one example
of a probability law.
But when things are that way,
if all outcomes are equally
likely and we have N of them,
and you have a set A that has
little n elements, then each
one of those elements has
probability one over
capital N since all
outcomes are equally likely.
And for our probabilities to add
up to one, each one must
have this much probability, and
there's little n elements.
That gives you the probability
of the event of interest.
So problems like the one in the
previous slide and more
generally of the type described
here under discrete
uniform law, these problems
reduce to just counting.
How many elements are there
in my sample space?
inside the event of interest?
Counting is generally simple,
but for some problems it gets
pretty complicated.
And in a couple of weeks, we're
going to have to spend
the whole lecture just on the
subject of how to count
systematically.
Now the procedure we followed in
the previous example is the
same as the procedure you would
follow in continuous
probability problems.
So, going back to our dart
problem, we get the random
point inside the square.
That's our sample space.
We need to assign a
probability law.
For lack of imagination, I'm
taking the probability law to
be the area of a subset.
So if we have two subsets of
the sample space that have
equal areas, then I'm
postulating that they are
equally likely to occur.
The probably that they fall
here is the same as the
probability that they
fall there.
The model doesn't have
to be that way.
But if I have sort of complete
ignorance of which points are
more likely than others,
that might be the
reasonable model to use.
So equal areas mean equal
probabilities.
If the area is twice as large,
the probability is going to be
twice as big.
So this is our model.
We can now answer questions.
Let's answer the easy one.
What's the probability
that the outcome is
exactly this point?
That of course is zero because
a single point has zero area.
And since this probability is
equal to area, that's zero
probability.
How about the probability that
the sum of the coordinates of
the point that we got is less
than or equal to 1/2?
How do you deal with it?
Well, you look at the picture
again, at your sample space,
and try to describe the event
that you're talking about.
The sum being less than 1/2
corresponds to getting an
outcome that's below this line,
where this line is the
line where x plus
y equals to 1/2.
So the intercepts of that line
with the axis are 1/2 and 1/2.
So you describe the event
visually and then you use your
probability law.
The probability law that we have
is that the probability
of a set is equal to the
area of that set.
So all we need to find is the
area of this triangle, which
is 1/2 times 1/2 times 1/2,
half, equals to 1/8.
OK.
Moral from these two examples is
that it's always useful to
have a picture and work with
a picture to visualize the
events that you're
talking about.
And once you have a probability
law in your hands,
then it's a matter of
calculation to find the
probabilities of an
event of interest.
The calculations we did in these
two examples, of course,
were very simple.
Sometimes calculations may be
a lot harder, but it's a
different business.
It's a business of calculus, for
example, or being good in
algebra and so on.
As far as probability is
concerned, it's clear what you
will be doing, and then maybe
you're faced with a harder
algebraic part to actually carry
out the calculations.
The area of a triangle
is easy to compute.
If I had put down a very
complicated shape, then you
might need to solve a hard
integration problem to find
the area of that shape, but
that's stuff that belongs to
another class that you have
presumably mastered by now.
Good, OK.
So now let me spend just a
couple of minutes to return to
a point that I raised before.
I was saying that the axiom that
we had about additivity
might not quite be enough.
Let's illustrate what I mean
by the following example.
Think of the experiment where
you keep flipping a coin and
you wait until you obtain heads
for the first time.
What's the sample space
of this experiment?
It might happen the first flip,
it might happen in the
tenth flip.
Heads for the first time might
occur in the millionth flip.
So the outcome of this
experiment is going to be an
integer and there's no bound
to that integer.
You might have to wait very
much until that happens.
So the natural sample
space is the set of
all possible integers.
Somebody tells you some
information about the
probability law.
The probability that you have
to wait for n flips is equal
to two to the minus n.
Where did this come from?
That's a separate story.
Where did it come from?
Somebody tells this to us, and
those probabilities are
plotted here as a
function of n.
And you're asked to find the
probability that the outcome
is an even number.
How do you go about calculating
that probability?
So the probability of being an
even number is the probability
of the subset that consists
of just the even numbers.
So it would be a subset of this
kind, that includes two,
four, and so on.
So any reasonable person would
say, well the probability of
obtaining an outcome that's
either two or four or six and
so on is equal to the
probability of obtaining a
two, plus the probability of
obtaining a four, plus the
probability of obtaining
a six, and so on.
These probabilities
are given to us.
So here I have to
do my algebra.
I add this geometric series and
I get an answer of 1/3.
That's what any reasonable
person would do.
But the person who only knows
the axioms that they posted
just a little earlier
may get stuck.
They would get stuck
at this point.
How do we justify this?
We had this property for the
union of disjoint sets and the
corresponding property that
tells us that the total
probability of finitely many
things, outcomes, is the sum
of their individual
probabilities.
But here we're using it on
an infinite collection.
The probability of infinitely
many points is equal to the
sum of the probabilities
of each one of these.
To justify this step we need
to introduce one additional
rule, an additional axiom, that
tells us that this step
is actually legitimate.
And this is the countable
additivity axiom, which is a
little stronger, or quite
a bit stronger, than the
additivity axiom
we had before.
It tells us that if we have a
sequence of sets that are
disjoint and we want to find
their total probability, then
we are allowed to add their
individual probabilities.
So the picture might
be such as follows.
We have a sequence of sets,
A1, A2, A3, and so on.
I guess in order to fit them
inside the sample space, the
sets need to get smaller
and smaller perhaps.
They are disjoint.
We have a sequence
of such sets.
The total probability of falling
anywhere inside one of
those sets is the sum of their
individual probabilities.
A key subtlety that's involved
here is that we're talking
about a sequence of events.
By "sequence" we mean that
these events can
be arranged in order.
I can tell you the first event,
the second event, the
third event, and so on.
So if you have such a collection
of events that can
be ordered as first, second,
third, and so on, then you can
add their probabilities
to find the
probability of their union.
So this point is actually a
little more subtle than you
might appreciate at this point,
and I'm going to return
to it at the beginning
of the next lecture.
For now, enjoy the first
week of classes
and have a good weekend.
Thank you.